hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, primarily, last… Thank you, thank you, thank you.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: This week, primarily, from the OCR, in addition part of things, we were starting on integration. We have…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay. We have…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we have started the integration part, and it is coming on along pretty good. Right now, we are able to ingest long PDFs, and we are getting a good, around 95%
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: accuracy with, like, on getting all the attributes out, but I recently, I just, I saw a bug because
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: When we're trying to OCR some of the PDFs,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, there's a difference between doing an OCR and looking at the underlying embedded text. So, in some cases, the OCR has given us a better output, and in some cases, the internal embedded
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like alphabets or letters are giving some better output so that part is something that we have to fix currently in the OCR part and after that we are planning to
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: align the schema that Liu has for the ML pipeline. We have the inputs ready for it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And we should be proceeding with that in the coming week.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I can maybe, like, there's not a demo as such, but I can quickly show you the last test run which I did.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Maybe it'll give you a bit more time on things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Just give me a second.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: As long as it's okay
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's right. So let me share my screen.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So this is one of the initial PDFs that we have had.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I was using this one, like, I just did a test on this one.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So it has a lot of stuff which is not really relevant, and the primary relevancy comes from the, like, spec doc, which is towards the bottom of it.
Harsha Tummala: Mmhm.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So we have two products, AccuHMOA, and there's one more, I think, OAW.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: They have similar, like, similar values.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Attributes and values.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, when we run into the pipeline,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Let me see if this is… oh, yeah. So this is a pipeline that would actually parse out what's relevant or what's not relevant, or do you have to manually
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: No, it automatically doesn't.
JakeMonroe: I was about to ask that too.
JakeMonroe: So it'll ignore those first couple pages, then, of just, like, more of the instructions and stuff.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, ideally, the OCR part just puts an order value, and the MN model is supposed to finally pass it out, because that's the main…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Part of this problem.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And so where's the hell?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: a disconnect here. So, you're saying your current stuff right now does not… does or does not
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: parts of that we'd have to wait to the Ml.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It does parse everything in the document that we have. Right. And we're still using an Llm. 5.4. So it does have some amount of context. But the final passing is going to be done by the end. Okay, the the exact relevancy will be done with Ml. Part. We parse out all the entire document, and, like the like, most relevant stuff is there? Like there, there's no data which is missing. But the final refinement will be done by the Ml. Part of things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, thanks for clarification.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And this is the, basically, the JSON dump that we currently
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: have… we need a few refinements, but, let's just see a few… This is the output from the parsing? Yeah, so we have the AQHMOA mounting configuration, pole mount.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We have the values along with them.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: These are, I did a check, these are around 95% accuracy as of right now. There are a few minor issues that is, related to a few of the… I'll be showing in the document itself.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So how do you measure? So provided was, I gave these documents to plot first. So then we make a goal set with plot like a table format, and then we run it through our past, and then we compare it, and then we get the editor.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I did the same thing. So, the problem I saw was in this part of things, because these have the OM symbol, and the OCR GPT-5 was reading it as QA, or Q2, in a few cases.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But if we pass it through a, something like a PDF plumber, it is supposed to give us a better output in this specific scenario. So I think that is something we'll take a look at next in order to reduce that error percentage even lower. So if we go back to the extracted stuffs.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What was it called?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Thermostat accuracy.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Where's books?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What else?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so here we have a 10K Q2. It is supposed to be 10K ohm.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, like, again, 10KQ to solo 10K home, so this is a slight mismatch.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But it is pretty minor, and we should be able to fix that and move ahead with it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: because here we are losing information that demo part will never get. So I think, right now we have like a 2 personality, and most of it comes from like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, symbols like ohms, and then even if there are images, I think sometimes GPT is kind of struggling, unless we use a union model, which is
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Gpt. 5.4 union Gpt. 5.4 vision. So when we take the union of both, we get a redo high school, which is less than one personality, and probably can fix this as well. But doing that would increase the costs overall, because
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We are sending it to the other employees.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then we take those, you know, the unions that are over with that. Well, the question is, what is the marginal cost?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, it's… it's gonna be a one-time cost of, like, $500 to $700. $500 if it's just
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: doing it once for all the datasets, and, like, telling others if they're doing it with both the… But that's everything in the e-parts. Yeah, everything on the e-parts catalog, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so this is, currently what we're doing in the oceanation part.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And yeah, I got a mail, Jake, with the upgrade PEM schema. I was going through it. I had a couple of questions around it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Let's see…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, in most of these, tables I'm seeing, you have… I think I'm assuming the code part is the ETEM code, and the standard is the standard it maps to. I think 2 maps to ETEM, and 3 is for E-Class.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, is there only, like, a particular row is supposed to have only one code? Like, not ETEM and ECLASS both?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Is that the case?
JakeMonroe: Yeah, we'll have a different row with ID Standard 3 for when we eventually move to, E-Class.
JakeMonroe: And then same, like, ID standard,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: duplicated this thing, like, two circuit breakers and fuses, if it has, IHC2 and 1, we'll have 3, the same.
JakeMonroe: Yeah, we'll need some kind of way to link them together, probably another table for us to map alias or map different standards together. But right now, in terms of just storing these, is this the category? Yeah, just for storing the categories, we're just going to have one. There could be multiple circuit breaker and fuse rows in here, depending on the different…
JakeMonroe: Standards, and we'll have to map that together with another table.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, okay, okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So initially, we were thinking about doing a bit of ETM part in the, before the ML portion, but, after…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, getting a bit further, that seems a bit difficult, so we need more information that we'll get after them part. So I think we'll, after we have a certain confidence course, we'll be using the schema you provided us, and kind of mapping all of it to that.
JakeMonroe: Great, thank you Yeah, and the reason for that, we just want to keep it flexible, too, for,
JakeMonroe: we could… I think standard 2… standard ID 2 just says ETIM, but really it should say, ETIM 10.0, and then when we get ETIM 12.0 a couple years from now, that can be a whole separate set of rows, or we can keep expanding. Otherwise, we'd have to have, you know, like, a column for each new standard we add in.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Right, right.
JakeMonroe: Yeah, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, yeah, that is, pretty much from the OCR part of things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I can show my workplace. Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You're, I'm, I'm already moved.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, that's excellent.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You can speak up. Yeah, am I audible, Jake?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You… yeah.
Harsha Tummala: Thank you so much.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, so let me just share my screen.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Thomas, let's see.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That is the one second.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So who's in Puerto Rico? Is this a fun thing in Puerto Rico? Someone with knee parts is in Puerto Ric.
JakeMonroe: Yeah, I… My wife's Puerto Rican, so I'm down here probably twice a year. This is… this is our usual summer… we do… we take a trip in the summer, usually, and around the holidays, too.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So what city are you in?
JakeMonroe: She's in Guaynabo, which is a, it's a suburb of San Juan, but yeah, San Juan, the,
JakeMonroe: Capital.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Very beautiful. I've been there once. Very nice.
JakeMonroe: Yeah, I love it down here.
JakeMonroe: Well, it's a little a little humid.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Thank you.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Hello?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, okay. So… I've been working on,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the ETMS class matching, so currently.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It is done. I still have to…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Get, do some revisions on this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I have tested it, and it's currently at around 92%.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: The…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: There are some errors in this one. And for example, like for this product type name and ETM class names, most of them match up well, but
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For some reason, when using the current rules, there are two components. First, it tries to see if the words match up.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Word by word, and if… if there… there is, something for that, then it tries to use that. And if not, it can call up, 5.4, using the Azure, token that I have.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But it's, it's still currently, I think, not,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Good enough, especially if you need to rerun it. If it, it was only very infrequent, then I think, the current approach should be enough, as the mistakes can be corrected, that they're pretty easy to spot. But if this is done again and again, then that's a little bit different.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So I'm still working on this and also the features that each of them have.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And I think I'll have a much more comprehensive,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think Jake has sent an integrated schema, like, with PIMS, which has all these already mapped. Oh.
JakeMonroe: No, no. So I don't have it mapped to the existing category. So this is great. But I do just have like a category table which has the ETIM category. But in terms of mapping it to the existing ALP ones, I haven't done any of that yet.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, okay, that's that's very good, then, because I would have just used that.
JakeMonroe: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I'll have much more to show on the, features, I think in a few days, but yeah, currently,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the, the classes and the… it is getting the… 92% of the time, it is getting the correct, class name for the product, names that are right now, and…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It does have, I don't think it's showing, but there are alternatives.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: for each of them. Some of them have no alternatives. But there is a little bit of
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I would say it's a hundred, it's not a hundred percent sure of what… which one…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's definitely the same one, so I'll work on that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, this is pretty much complete. How many roles in this take roles?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Currently, it's 38 382 rooms, that's all.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For the ETM standard. That's it. No, the ETM standard is much larger than that. Yes. But what.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What we have, what, what the number that was available.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: is, is, that it's being matched, yeah, the ETM standard is actually being… There's multiple, there's ETM groups, classes, or attributes, so there are multiple, like, there is ETM values for all of these, but there are different, like, different types of, like, it could be a, it could be a value, it could be a class name, so these are different number of…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And not all of them are specialists.
JakeMonroe: And I think, which you'll see in, in, in what I, in what I sent over earlier, the groupings, I just made, I made groups a category in addition to,
JakeMonroe: Not feature.
JakeMonroe: what's class, a category as well. And I just made, essentially, class a, a child category that had, a parent category of what I translated the groups to. So I did cram groups and classes both into the same category, schema.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think we can take a look at that and come back to you with questions.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's a little different on my side, but yeah, that guy, I think I can also account for that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, so this one in co-pilot or something in azure. How did how did you do this?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: First, there's a rule space word by word matching. Okay. And then…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: When that was not, that was not working. Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I just used the Azure Foundry token for ChatGPT 5.4 to do the matches for the rest. And the verification was done just using
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: There's there's a worldly set of things that was already available that the
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It already had… it did not have for all of them, but it did have a large enough number that I could compare against, so it was around 92%.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That that's, I've not checked each of them. Yeah, we'll figure those points there. Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So on the ML side, Leo has been working primarily on, like, just setting up the fundamental, like, and I don't want to go over the whole milestone plan that we had laid out. So, I started building on top of it, since Monday, so I picked up three tasks. So one is, I set up the load testing for our, prediction service.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: so up until now we would only like we only measured it like one request at a time so we actually had no idea if it holds up under the real traffic right so I kind of build a harness to you know to just check if it keeps up with the concurrent request and also like check whether it keeps up with the
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, a 50,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Queries, like, per second, while staying under the 200 millisecond target latency that we had initially planned on.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: so that is kind of validated in the load testing part my PR are up we have not yet merged it because simultaneously I've also worked on like setting up a CI on the repo so as per our QA plan and the testing plan which is all like in the air and theoretical we kind of have like more than two
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think 250 test cases.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But, nothing till date was actually running on any of the pull requests, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the build column, if you see, once the PRs get merged, were, like, mostly empty. So, like, from now onwards, like, every PR that runs, that gets merged would run the whole test suite, plus the linting and the type checks automatically. So, from now onwards, probably we'll have a better,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, defect catching strategy before the actual stuff gets merged. So that was about the load testing and the CI that I set up on the repo.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And also, like, one important thing that I also took up was I… we ran our evaluation with the rule engine, turned on. So, like, I… I mean, I looked up,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I looked at the numbers actually the old eval numbers were like bad basically by bad what I mean is basically like there was like zero autopressing but that's because it I I believe that's because it was only running the semantic match or half of the pipeline like which was kind of capping the
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: confidence, confidence numbers artificially. So, the numbers were kind of misleading, so I kind of wired the, rules back in and re-ran the whole, evaluation pipeline. So, now we kind of have, like, realistic accuracy. I mean, I've…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, the numbers are low because I'm not yet run on the proper data. But I think by end of tomorrow, we'll have realistic numbers and we'll have more accurate numbers and also the auto process numbers for the entire pipeline end to end. And also since the OCR and the ingestion is also taking some shape, so we were planning by this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: end of the week, maybe, like, if things go smoothly.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: whatever we have on the ML side as of today, given, plus the OCR and the ingestion work, we might, do a, like, a run with the actual data and see how,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: how that works, because right now, Arjun and Rishi, they also got a good idea about the… how… what is the input expectation of the ML pipeline, so I think they're gonna… they are working on it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So I think by end of this week, we'll have, I mean, we are not expecting a smooth pipeline setup, but at least we'll have like pretty good number of defects and probably we can work on the entire three modules as of date, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So we talked about.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Subset of real name, or all of them? A subset of the real name.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: albeit subset.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Don't worry.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: No, I think Liu will have better… like, I think since he had, like, good understanding of the data, like, maybe he can tell us, like, how much amount of data we can use. Because, like he said, we have a problem with our validation data, right? So…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I don't know how we will work through that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yes, so… I think it's a good idea to use real data to test an ML model, because
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: and… So, the model is trained by the
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: description or the data they give us. So I use the fabricated data to test the model.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the the result could be plausible. And also.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: in their fails, many products, their attributes are
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: only have one or 2 samples. So the data is Oh.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: very, very extremely like sparsely distribution data. So we have.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: so maybe that's one reason.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Why, the user data to test the model, the result would be happy and not so good as it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: should be shown before. Yeah, no doubt that. Yes, the the real question is, how much of the real data are you planning on using?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, I… use, like, 30 million rolls.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: 30 million.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, in my, in my bank, right?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think that's what we have used already. Like, we're asking about the new data that we will need. Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For testing, how much will we need?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Real data.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You mean the data to validate the model.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: like, only… Perfect.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Tens… tens of thousands.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: 10,000. Okay. Yeah, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, maybe you subtitle.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Subject.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Those. 30,000.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Close, okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, but that's not that much.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh… Okay, I think, from the update's point of view, that was…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: pretty much all we have right now. We will try to, finalize the post-generation and link it with
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the ML part by the end of next week, but that is slightly optimistic, but yeah, we'll try to do the best, and we'll try to have… try to deliver some sort of an MVP to you guys as a proper demo by the end of the month. So, like, after fixing all the minor bugs that we have currently.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, at that time, there should be a… Like, decently working.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: at least those generation and some sort of Ml values will be getting from the data.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, intense.
JakeMonroe: Great.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, it's all from our side. Anything for you guys.
Harsha Tummala: I mean, no, no more questions for me. That's pretty much it. I think I was waiting for like a document from Liu about the technical implementation of the Msn.
Harsha Tummala: I don't know who to send it to us, just checking.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, I forgot it. I have to send it, after the meeting.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, Liu forgot to send the document. He's saying he's… he'll send after the meeting. Yeah, yeah, I.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, that's, that's pretty much all the questions I had. And with respect to like just getting the pipeline ready, I would also say like it would help, if you guys, like just check with the timeline of like events in the next two, three weeks, because I know end of semester are coming up.
Harsha Tummala: And yeah, just, just, just, just making sure that
Harsha Tummala: We're all, like, aware, and, like, we're, like, accommodating to all that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yep.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we should be able to accommodate this along with the NSAMs.
Harsha Tummala: Makes sense.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, Jake, when do you come back to Pittsburgh?
JakeMonroe: I'll be back Wednesday, I guess Tuesday night, but like Wednesday, technically at like whatever, 12:30 AM, something like that, late flight in.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Is that a direct flight, or do you have to go somewhere else?
JakeMonroe: I wish…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's always.
JakeMonroe: It's always a connection.
Harsha Tummala: So…
JakeMonroe: Always a connection. Past couple times, it's been easier to just drive to DC and fly out of DC rather than deal with a tight connection and all that. It's, yeah.
Harsha Tummala: Apparently, Pittsburgh Airport is getting more international flights next year around the world.
Harsha Tummala: Based on words, I think.
JakeMonroe: Think so.
Harsha Tummala: I have to go to the bas.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Well, enjoy the rest of your time in Puerto Rico.
JakeMonroe: Thank you. Thank you.
Harsha Tummala: And.
Harsha Tummala: See you guys, bye bye, have a.
JakeMonroe: Do you… do you have.